- My name is Ella, and I love pranks.
I one time pranked my boss at work
by putting baby goats in his office.
(goat crying)
So let me tell you the story
of the time I pranked my
family with an emu egg.
(laughing)
So, my friend at work, Sara Rubin,
ordered a bunch of emu eggs.
I think she was filming a video
where she had people make
omelets out of emu eggs.
She asks me if I want to keep one,
and I say, yeah, definitely.
Like, I'm gonna figure
out what to do with it.
I have this emu egg.
My parents have a chicken coop.
I'm gonna put this emu egg in the coop
where the chickens lay the eggs,
and I'm gonna see what their reaction is.
This footage was actually
captured two years ago,
but I hadn't done anything with it yet,
and I decided, now is the time.
So they have this coop, they
have these two chickens,
the chickens are cute.
I don't live there, but I
thought, how funny would it be
if I put this egg inside of their coop
and made it seem like
the chicken laid the egg?
- [Luka] Ugh, flip flops.
- So my mom is really gullible,
and my dad is just a
Brazilian, aloof kind of guy.
Like, it's pretty easy to trick them.
- [Mother] Oh my God!
- We were filming secretly, I
had the camera in my pocket.
- [Mother] What is that?
(mumbles) put that there or something.
Dear God.
- [Luka] Oh my God.
- [Father] What?
- [Ella] What?
- My mom is a religious
Mexican-American woman,
and she was not having it.
She was like, this is some devil (bleep).
Like, what happened?
- That's a real egg.
Oh my God, it's like a super chicken.
If those little chickens can
lay these eggs, we are rich.
There's something inside.
- [Luka] No, stop, bring it inside.
- [Ella] Bring it inside.
- This might be out of space.
It has to do with a meteor.
- [Mother] It's scaring me.
- [Ella] Just touch it.
- [Father] Shake it.
It's like a.
- [Luka] Do you think we're going
to make money off these chickens?
- If they lay eggs like this,
we can have a thousand
chickens that'll worth 'em.
- [Mother] No, come on.
- [Ella] I want Mom to crack it.
- I don't like this.
- [Ella] I want to see what's inside.
- It doesn't crack.
- [Ella] You have to do
it hard, I don't know.
- [Ella] I want to see what's inside.
Crack it.
- Crack it hard.
- Crack it.
- [Luka] Don't spill it out please.
- [Luka] I need to see
what's in there, now.
You gotta just get dirty, Mom.
- Just a minute, just a minute,
because I'm really, God,
this is, like, really bad.
(screams)
Oh my God!
There's a egg in here?
Jesus Christ.
- [Ella] Crack it open, I want to see.
I want to see.
Crack it open.
(screams)
- Oh my God!
What the hell
kind of animal
does that?
(laughing)
- That yolk came out,
and she was freaked out.
(screams)
- Oh my God.
- You did this.
- [Luka] We pranked ya!
- She was mad at me.
I'm not gonna lie, like,
the reason why I hadn't
made this video yet
was because she told me
not to, but here we are.
Are you mad that I pranked you?
- No, I thought it was a lot of fun.
And very smart, yeah.
I think Mom was the one who really got it.
- [Ella] What did you think it was, Mom?
- [Ella] Like what?
- [Ella] Did you think
the chickens laid it?
- No, I was pretty sure the
chickens hadn't laid it,
but I thought it might be some
animal that had gotten in.
Somehow, it was living in the coop
and I was gonna have do
deal with some scary animal.
- Their reaction was so hilarious,
and there was really no harm done.
Like, what else was I going
to do with this emu egg?
I had to prank them.
What do you think the chickens thought
when they went in there?
- They might have to go
to a psychologist now
for, like, a session.
- I don't like pranks.
- Okay, well I do.
Anyway, thank you so much
for watching this video.
Like it, like the video.
Don't share it though,
'cause I don't want my mom to see this.
(orchestral music)